[Musique]
vu du ciel c'est un immeuble presque
comme les autres mais ici les travaux
sont à l'arrêt depuis un an et demi
c'est un chantier abandonné et c'est sa
maison
étrangler par ses dettes you Gong Fu a
emménagé ici il y a trois mois
actuellement les travaux ne sont pas
finis
regardez il reste des outils du mastic
des planches tout est resté comme tel
il y en a même à l'intérieur des
appartements
il n'a nulle part où aller comme tous
les propriétaires dans ce bâtiment il a
acheté sur plan à un promoteur au bord
de la faillite ces logements devaient
être livrés en juin 2021
voilà l'endroit où je vis maintenant
40 mètres carrés pour 45000 euros des
conditions de vie spartiate il se
débrouille avec d'autres propriétaires
l'un de mes voisins est électricien donc
il a réussi à faire les branchements
pour qu'on ait du courant dans la
chambre
mais c'est seulement pour avoir la
lumière et pour charger nos téléphones
portables ou d'autres petits appareils
pas de courant que non plus juste des
réservoirs d'eau de pluie plusieurs fois
le promoteur a promis de reprendre les
travaux des promesses non tenues
l'entreprise n'a pas les fonds
nécessaires
hugofu n'a plus la force de se battre
quand on a défendu nos droits on a été
réprimé plusieurs fois par la police je
ne comprends pas pourquoi je suis
considéré comme un mauvais citoyen juste
parce que j'ai acheté un appartement pas
terminé
que dire je peux seulement attendre
trois mois plus tôt les propriétaires
font pression sur le promoteur ils
occupent tout le rez-de-chaussée
racontent leur combat sur les réseaux
sociaux une mobilisation grave en Chine
mais ça ne dure pas certains sont même
arrêtés par la police
aujourd'hui il ne reste que li 24 ans
ironie du sort c'est un ancien agent
immobilier maintenant au chômage
comme j'ai besoin d'argent pour vivre et
pour rembourser mon emprunt j'ai appris
à vendre ses grillades dans la rue
lis gagne seulement une dizaine d'euros
par jour il se demande quand il recevra
son appartement
ça peut traîner encore 8 ans voir 10 ans
à coup de Ming certains bâtiments n'ont
pas été livrés même après une dizaine
d'années
font partie du paysage en Chine 40% des
acheteurs attendent les clés de
l'horlogements parce que dans tout le
pays une trentaine de promoteurs croule
sous des centaines de milliards d'euros
de dettes incapables de terminer les
chantiers la colère des propriétaires
sont en même dans la rue
près d'un million d'entre eux refusent
de rembourser leurs emprunts tant que
leurs appartements ne seront pas livrés
ces images sont vite censurées des
réseaux sociaux pour cette économiste
l'ampleur du mouvement alarme les
autorités
je pense que le gouvernement va
probablement intervenir comme prêteur en
dernier recours pour s'assurer que les
projets soient terminés parce que le
vrai problème pour le gouvernement c'est
la crédibilité et la confiance des
acheteurs et des investisseurs
le secteur immobilier représente près
d'un cinquième du PIB chinois il est
donc crucial pour la santé globale de
l'économie la crise frappe aussi les
producteurs d'acier de béton et toutes
les petites entreprises de construction
les victimes collatérales ce sont les
ouvriers au pied des tours ils ont
déserté les baraquements se mettre
d'oeuvres à vue tous ses employés partir
il n'y a plus d'argent on ne touche rien
ici les ouvriers ont travaillé pendant
quatre ou cinq mois mais ils ont été
payés moins de 300 euros comment
peuvent-ils survivre
son entreprise lui laisse se
préfabriquer un salut pour vivre sans
salaire sans être financière
franchement on en peut plus de
solliciter le gouvernement on a déjà
demandé de l'aide au Département du
Travail de la construction mais rien à
faire
pour atténuer le choc le gouvernement
prévoit plus de 150 milliards d'euros de
prêts pour soulager les promoteurs pas
sûr que cela suffise à sauver le secteur
immobilier ancien moteur de la
croissance devenu un frein de l'économie
chinoise